Jared's with us in Oklahoma City
hi Jared how are you doing great day
very better than I deserve what's up
what have you been helping you settle a
debate or dispute I had with some of my
fellow YouTube crazy they want me to
sell off all my totally to get out of
debt the only issue is my toys are the
only things keeping the in debt okay
thirty thousand dollars on a truck I'm
how much on the truck thirty thousand
thirty thousand dollar truck okay and
what else I'm gonna be saving up to pay
cash for a truck I'm gonna sell that get
rid of it in the next six lock I have a
boat $9,300 on mmm-hmm and I have a
Harley that's paid off
mmm-hmm what's the hardly worth and
what's your household income okay well I
mean there's three ways to look at this
one is just keep all of it and work your
way through it how long does that take
you too long okay yeah the second way is
sell everything today and you're
debt-free and you're driving a $10,000
car paid for because that's what the
Harley will buy you I don't know if are
upside down on the truck are you eating
okay so you can break even on the truck
break even on the boat
Harley I'll buy you a car our truck or
whatever for ten grand right and you
make seventy are you single yes sir okay
or you could do something kind of in the
middle if you wanted okay I mean if you
sold the truck which the truck kind of
needs to go it's kind of it's the
ridiculous thing on the list oh yeah you
know it's almost happy it's almost half
your annual income tied up and you got a
lot of stuff going down in value with
motors in it so you can't have more than
half your annual income tied up and
stuff with motors in it if you want to
win with money because you eats all
going the wrong way so you know decide
but I'm gonna get rid of the truck and
then I'd probably which one do you like
better the boat of the Harley
I kind of split I like both of them it's
my first boat I bought it this last
spring but I love both of them okay you
can't tell boat with a Harley
oh well that's true but I mean you can
talk about whether without $10,000 truck
that's like ash for ya if you saw one of
them well my theory was I wasn't going
to get rid of the truck and keep the
boat paying off
keep the Harley you know what are you
gonna drive and you're gonna drive
something why I think in seven or eight
thousand dollar truck that you pay so
you've got twenty thousand dollars in
debt to pay off in under a year pays off
the boat you keep the boat the Harley
and have a ten thousand dollar car right
or ten thousand all right that fits the
point is you know when you want to when
do you want to be out of debt and you
just ask yourself that question and then
and what are you willing to do it sounds
like you could be a hundred percent
debt-free if you sold the truck and
bought a ten thousand dollar truck in a
year and that that's acceptable in my
mind and but and then you just got to
decide are you gonna keep doing this the
rest of your life because dude I mean
you're putting money and stuff that's
going the wrong way I like boats and
Harley's and cars and trucks I like all
that stuff I'm a boy I like stuff with
motors in it but but but you know I
don't like being broke either and right
now you're just broke the plan if you're
through and you want to take a year and
hold on to a couple of these items
that's fine the interesting thing I
found out is this after doing this a
long time Jarrett is you know the thing
about a car boat or a Harley unless it's
just you've had the boat here how long
you had the Harley now I mean two years
from now if you were sitting on fifty
thousand cash and you were debt-free I
don't know if you'd go buy that boat or
that Harley you know so I'm not sure
it's worth it to fight that hard to keep
them is my point
I mean again you can get what you want
but if you were a hundred percent
debt-free by the end of the week
by selling all three items and driving a
$10,000 truck how quickly what would you
buy a year from now if you had $30,000
cash set aside for toys perhaps would it
be those things oh no how do I be buying
another house oh well then maybe the
toys need to go you know I mean that's
all another way of looking at it it just
makes you think through it
I always think through if I didn't have
the stuff would I go buy it again and
that that sometimes jogs me lose from
something I think is there so the
beautiful thing is Jarrod you're single
you make $70,000 with the decision that
you make today you can be debt-free in a
year or less and have this stuff or not
have this stuff and be on your way to
doing whatever you want to do so just do
it do it on purpose
be intentional and there's no actual
complete right or wrong thing to do
based on what you told me other than I
wouldn't keep this truck the truck does
not fit in the equation what would Dave
Ramsey do I probably sell it all because
I've been through enough cycles of
buying toys in my life that I'm probably
gonna buy different toys and when I get
a little bit further along maybe a notch
up or two and Harley a notch up or two
and vote maybe and pay cash for it and
it might be two years and I might buy
rental property in the meantime like you
said or something like that so you know
I've just been through that a couple
times and I'm not as attached to any of
these items with motors in them like I
used to be so but I start probably
cleaning it all out just to be free and
then set myself on a course to buy some
other stuff later pretty quickly but
it's not a bad thing if you want to hold
it for a year there's not it's not a
absolute like you're a stupid person or
something kind of thing hey thanks for
calling it hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]